Wow some big news rattling Washington
tonight the Department of Justice's
Inspector General is officially
investigating whether the FBI or the DOJ
broke laws when it used FISA warrants to
spy on an American citizen
most likely former Trump campaign
adviser Carter Paige we first learned of
these alleged abuses when the president
Declassified a house Intel committee
memo remember it detailed how the FBI
used an unverified dossier funded by the
Democrats to spy on mr. Paige now I've
long said the Inspector General is key
to getting to the bottom of what
happened here and to discuss further
let's bring in House Judiciary Committee
Chairman Bob Goodlatte a Republican from
Virginia and here in Washington has been
reporting on this byron york chief
political correspondent for the
Washington Examiner and Fox News
contributor
all right gentlemen big news tonight
congressman Goodlatte there's been a
stonewalling taking place at the DOJ
through the FBI for months and months
and months you guys think you out like
three million or 1 minute 1.2 million
documents you've gotten three thousand
documents maybe it's just too many
documents you want maybe the copy
machine is broken I mean what's the
what's the justification for this delay
well the Department does not have a good
justification for the delay the Attorney
General and the director of the FBI
Christopher ray have both acknowledged
that to me they now say they are hard at
work getting those documents ready for
us the requirement of the subpoena that
I issued last Thursday is that it those
documents get to us by next Thursday in
the meantime we are pleased that the
Inspector General has announced that he
will also look into this matter but two
things one the Inspector General can't
look at it from the same perspective the
Congress can or from the perspective
that an independent Special Counsel can
and secondly the Inspector General
should get out his report with regard to
the investigation he's been conducting
for the past year with regard to how the
FBI handled the Clinton email
investigation first we need
information out now and then he can go
on and look at the other matter and in
the meantime we need the documents that
we've subpoenaed by we need them
unredacted yeah go to you on this I mean
Jeff Sessions kind of come around on
this but man this has been going on
it's rigmarole as my mother used to say
has been going around for a long time
there is very little trust among
Republicans on Capitol Hill and the
Republican Justice Department about this
because this has been going on a long
time remember Paul Ryan said the FBI was
stonewalling the House Intelligence
Committee months and months and months
ago why now why does Jeff sessions now
see it as a problem I think there are a
couple of reasons going on first of all
you know that the the text between Peter
straw can lisa page a lot of those were
handed over to the congress and a lot of
those were redacted and the Justice
Department said well you know they were
having an affair and there was some
personal stuff in there so that's you
know we just had to redact the personal
stuff well a couple of members of the
House Judiciary Committee have been
going over the Justice Department and
looking at fuller versions of those
texts and finding out that some actual
real official material evidence was left
out of those was was redacted and the
ones that sent over so there is ZERO
trust there and I think the fact that
the Judiciary Committee is sending
people over every day to look at this
stuff at the Justice Department has
probably told the FBI they're not going
to give up chairman Goodlatte when you
when you think about these texts and
news tonight broke that Denis McDonough
of course the White House chief of staff
for Barack Obama was mentioned and at
least one looks like more text between
struck and page and I guess the concern
is what the concern is the White House
was not just kept abreast of this
investigation of the Trump campaign but
you know that you've see it online
already people are wondering were they
directing it and if so that's a big
problem it's a very big problem we're
not passing judgment on that at this
point but our point is you can't make a
decision in the Congress about what is
material
over at the Justice Department we have
another example we know that Peter
struck and Lisa Paige we're talking
about a federal judge who was appointed
to the FISA Court and mr. struck said oh
he's a friend of mine I'm gonna go meet
with him that was redacted as well we
don't know whether anything wrong took
place in whatever conversations they had
but that was material evidence that was
withheld from us Carrie by redacting
materials
yeah that's judge we need the unredacted
materials well yeah we just have too
many there are too many instances of
either an appearance of a conflict
perhaps an actual conflict political
affiliations going back to Hillary or
the Clinton Foundation or Ben Rhodes and
now this the contreras is a friend of
Paige and struck and that's not revealed
in Byron I'm telling you this this gives
everybody a sense of heightened concern
that this investigation from the
beginning was the insurance policy was
an insurance policy and the in the fall
of 2016
heaven forbid should something have
happened with Hillary maybe her health
or who knows maybe Donald Trump was
gonna win even though they didn't think
he would because when you see Denis
McDonough on those texts and what what
gives a lot of Republicans problems is a
lot of them thought Republican president
Republican Congress then the Justice
Department will cooperate with the
Republican Congress and that didn't
happen what they realized what there
were apparently institutional
prerogatives and and and back covering
understand that's called the deep state
back covering instincts so strong over
there that they were they were stronger
than any desire to actually cooperate
with this Republican Congress so you've
seen this adversarial atmosphere
developed between people in the same
party there's one other thing and I want
to play as we're a little bit over but
senator Blumenthal was on CNN today I
want I'd love for you chairman Goodlatte
to respond to this this is about the
expulsion of the 60 Russian diplomats
let's watch do you give the president
credit for what is considered what many
say is a very strong step stronger than
what the President Obama had done I give
the president credit for expelling 60
Russian Intel
officers I think that it is diminished
in its force by the president's failure
to himself break his silence on Vladimir
Putin instead of pushing back as
aggressively as he should he
congratulated Putin on his election they
have to keep on this narrative for the
Muller investigation it's Russia Russia
Russia chairman Goodlatte you close it
out well this is far beyond what a few
Democrats or a lot of Democrats think
about Donald Trump this is about how the
government including possibly the White
House in the Obama administration but
certainly the Federal Bureau of
Investigation and the Justice Department
may have subverted justice in a
dramatically different way they handled
the Hillary Clinton email investigation
and how they attempted to conduct an
investigation into the Trump campaign it
is stunning
how that the contrast takes place here
and both Republicans Democrats and
independents everyone should be
concerned about this because we don't
want the same thing to happen in the
next election you can't have the most
important law-enforcement organization
in the world conducting itself in the
manner it did in 2016 and on into 27
look there's a lot more news that's
coming tomorrow night and we're gonna
bring that to here on the Ingraham angle
gentlemen thank you